hey speaking of musicians everybody was
obsessed with that mark McGrath cameo
video yesterday of him helping a guy
break up it was crank yeah I mean I
don't think that's that
shocking I was playing it yesterday and
just didn't even watch it the first
thing she said though oh is that mark
McGrath as I can she was like is that it
somebody do that as a joke one of these
six I didn't see it I was like oh yeah
probably
I guess they probably did so mark
McGrath he's on cameo and a hundred
dollars is what it cost to get him
it's what cameos you know where you get
celebrities and you pay him and they
make little videos for you
and this video came out and it was him
helping somebody break up with their
significant other and as it turns out
this is a real cameo but the person who
hired him to do it it was a joke it
wasn't a real breakup it is mark McGrath
from the band sugar ray off the charts
but always in your hearts and this cameo
was Versailles he starts every cameo
like that off the charts but still in
your hearts all of the Cameo start like
that I'd rather eat sharks and she wants
you to know a few things and this is a
little difficult for me to say because
it's the first one of these I've done
but she wants you to know that you mean
a lot to her you mean the world to her
but she's having difficulty staying in
this long-distance relationship you know
it's tough I've been on the road for
years and I've been with my wife a long
time and the biggest arguments the
biggest you know obstacles in our
relationships is the distance between us
it makes it very difficult when around
the road and it's hard so Cheyenne is
trying to let you know brain dead it's
very very tough for her to stay in this
relationship she still cares about you a
lot you never know what the future may
hold and she still wants to be friends
with you because obviously she cares
about you very very much and she wants
you to know good luck on your thei
is coming up the best timing Cheyenne
when he's doing his thesis but I
understand you know you gotta work on
your thesis and I think she's trying to
be mark McGrath how could somebody break
down any problem why this go viral who
cares because it's mark McGrath from
Sugar Ray breaking a couple up that's
funny ah I couldn't get through this
freak okay well you don't need to insult
mark McGrath I mean his face isn't
moving well you get I can't wait to see
you at that age you've already had two
cosmetic surgeries done how old is Mark
he's younger right and not any younger
than Troy hold is it how old is Troy how
old is Mark 51 that's so close Jed a lot
of work done yeah Troy you'll be there
very very soon you've already had
rhinoplasty and breast augmentation so
what do you think it's gonna be next
good point you know name you I would be
real careful about the shots are taken
now far behind me there Roberts yeah but
I haven't had any any cosmetic surgeries
done pretty obviously yet they're coming
wait till the insults start flying on
just see me coming in with like super
inflated cheeks and my forehead doesn't
move anymore big lips I hope I get there
I hope I just lose it a bad wig what are
you doing even kirlyam do you hope I go
through a crisis like that right ring
bleaching your hair for a while it would
make me so happy
if I get you went through a period of
time right like over the course of six
months every you know every month or so
you came in and you had altered your
physical appearance like a lot and you
wanted you pretend like it was no big
deal like what you started wearing
bright colors just to start JK now all
of a sudden you were in bright colors no
more like roots of fight hoodies all
wear expensive stuff and bright colors
and it's like what's lets Jim up to I
don't know and then we start to notice
that you get that thing where you got it
tightened you got the facelift like
under your chin but you can totally tell
this pin back behind your ears bleached
hair
then you get your hair bleached then
your your face stop stopping yeah yeah
they smooth at the little between your
between your eyes or wrinkled thing that
everybody getting crazy is going on it's
politics
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM f
[Music]